hello everybody in what exact uh hey
look a creeper hey hey guys serious
no oh you didn't even notice them I made
it mom joke ice no that's totally
totally blocked you out for a while
right okay that's like my favorite sound
I see it I'm gonna go blow it all don't
blew it up
zombie don't let me blow it up it's my
stepping up I'll blow them up
don't blow it why are we doing why are
we in a grave ah
I have a flint in stone no [ __ ] you
killed ah I got it oh yeah I reckon
Tommy I'm gonna die why haven't I laid
stone tools yet see this is drunk as a
terrible idea I'm still using wooden
tool I'm on fire sounds like a personal
problem in a good way or a bad way tied
he looks like a job job from Star Wars a
job job you know that you know what a
chop job you know the traitor thingies
ja wohl yeah that nothing job job shun
me shut up with a joke job you could see
the relation no I'm gonna know it shut
up ed you seen Star Wars at least
once in your life you know it's not a
job job I've seen it many many times I
thought it weave in reverse I thought it
was a job job you're the best one torch
alone here your dick
throw them you're the brother ah almost
have burned it out fire again
oh this is my favorite hey kid
I can't do them zombie not bad you're
not working here we go
I have a [ __ ] we might be done
oh look at the trap oh my God we're
gonna crash the server oh yeah we're
gonna be oh oh my god yes
I'm too framed for a second oh I'm
drinking to this although did you die
Logan lava hurts interesting sidenote
lava hurts love that morgue finally
found a chest no I found a switch I
found that chest Alice's lover oh and
here no we barely knew him Wow what what
is this what is this Moe's to be my love
confession to who you well here's what I
think of your love confession oh [ __ ]
goodbye I bet mark got his dynamite out
and blew some stuff Oh Castle is this
guy weights got canceled is this guy
yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] I to the sky look I
owe my mom [ __ ] your cat look at that oh
my god okay there might be something in
the lava hang on let me check
I only came in are you dead yet no I'm
I'm mysteriously being healing ah I got
it what what's wrong with you guys stop
okay right mark finish it off man I
didn't start for you bye-bye